last time the dodgers won the world
series was 1988
dodgers with a huge win yesterday a
must-have
uh and one that uh you know normally you
take a look at
you think that this can change an entire
series um
they go tonight in game four of the nlcs
after
putting up an 11 spot it's interesting
that's not technically a crooked number
is it normally
you know you know you're right you're
right you're right when you say put up a
crooked number it's a lot of runs
uh it's not really a crooked number but
it's a it's a number
uh it's a whopping find number to use a
dr seuss phrase um
and now uh it's now two to one in terms
of the braves lead
they're starting a 22 year old
wet behind the ears and bryce wilson
it's his eighth career start tonight
and clayton kershaw making his 28th
career postseason start so we figured
let's uh dial up
uh somebody who i'm uh i'm a fan of not
just from his days
pitching uh for the los angeles dodgers
and the cleveland indians and
uh his stellar baseball career but also
his broadcasting career in los angeles
he and joe davis are an outstanding
listen and watch here
um he's oral hersheiser how are you sir
good morning
doing great i'm pleased to have you on
so oh
do you what what do you take out of uh
yesterday
just one win or or this is the uh the
change of the tide here or the big blue
dodger blue wave if you will in this
series
oral and i think when you take a step
back to the beginning of the series when
it was ooo
um everybody thought the dodgers were
the overwhelming favorite but the braves
would be the best competition they had
faced all year
when they lost game one i felt like the
series was even
uh when they lost game two i thought
they were down again
and now with the two one you know
totals i think that the dodgers are back
to even almost because of what you see
now even in the
starting pitching matchup today with
kershaw and against wilson who
never had a playoff start has only like
seven big league starts
so i think that this is a point where
clayton kershaw steps up in a big game
and continues to improve his postseason
resume
and i think the dodgers pull within or
even after the night
and so um what do you know or glean
about his
uh his back i mean you must know quite a
bit about has his history of battling
with it and
how he has been able to bounce back from
it previously what do you think about
right now
oral well they've they've adjusted his
workouts throughout as he's gotten a
little older in the wear and tear
because he was here at such a young age
and put so many innings so they've
adjusted the workouts and clayton has
been very open to adjusting where in the
past
he's admitted that his workouts and his
stubbornness of of who he is and
how he goes about his business and what
his regimen is he was very strict about
that
from the time he got up in the morning
to what he ate to when he worked out to
what workouts he did in what order
everything like that but this year and
the past year
he's really adjusted to his body and to
reality really
and so i'm really confident i think that
i was very confident
that once he got scratched but he went
out and did his workouts he did his dry
work
his long toss he did a little side work
that told me that the back was good
enough to pitch
but they weren't sure how deep into the
game it would hold up
so to get two more days i think that
that were
a lot more confident that he can go you
know at least 75 to 90 pitches
and the whole question mark coming into
the outing is not going to be how the
back is at the beginning is it's how
how it loosens up throughout the day and
um in terms of the the braves um
and uh uh do you think the dodgers have
solved
their their their pitching uh that that
had been so dominant throughout this
entire month of october up until the
ninth inning of game two
do you think this has been a solve um i
think that
they have picked on the underbelly of
the pitching and i think the braves are
still
in that position here with what they're
starting today
so i'm not sure you could say that about
wright and freed yet
and that will probably be part of the
story going into game six and seven if
we get there
and i think that uh the dodgers though
are starting to get hot and to get
confident so
as a whole lineup you can't turn to any
guy in their lineup and say oh he's in a
slump or he's not
on on target right now when you look at
the braves lineup
you say okay when's a cuny you know
cocoon you're going to get going when's
ozuna going to get going and you
probably are going to say as any kind of
pitcher right now don't let freddie
freeman beat you
so i think the key right now is the
dodgers are hitting as a whole lineup
and feel real confident because of
yesterday and the braves are still
looking for where are we going to fire
on all cylinders
and it'll be interesting because i think
the dodgers line up with confidence and
swinging about well
can hit almost any pitching where the
braves uh i might all of a sudden run
into a buzz saw where the dodger
pitching could be in line
oral hershey's are here on the rich
eisen show and you've obviously
been well versed on um
how long it's been for the dodgers and
as well as
how good these teams have been uh in
recent years is this the best version of
the dodgers do you think this is the
best
team uh or do you think they have had a
better team that just
didn't get the breaks or couldn't get it
done what do you think
no i think i think this is the best team
because a you you had mookie bets
and then david price has gone uh you
know because he opted out
uh so let's just start with bets that's
adding best to any team makes you a
better team than you were the year
before and i think that's
amazing the part that would make you
think well this can't be as good a team
because you lose all the starting pitchy
from david price to miata to rich hill
to ryu
and you go how can that be but then
you've got dustin may stepping in tony
gonzone stepping in julio ria stepping
in
so i think that balances the books on
the pitching and then bets puts you over
the top
and the way this team has performed in
the past in the playoffs
it's usually been the offense and a
little bit of the pitching that has
failed them so
the what they've done offensively this
year of not chasing
of hitting for power of grinding out at
bats of taking their walks
they needed to continue that into the
playoffs and they really have except for
the first two games
well first game in three quarters
because the game won they got shot down
by free
and then and then they get shut down for
about seven innings in game two
but now they're hitting like themselves
so i think this is the best team they've
had going into the playoffs not because
we're just talking present tense
well i and then you know i guess again
very you have every right to be proud of
the 1988 team but
i think here in the dodgers fan base
they're kind of sick and tired of
keeping on talking about it right they
just want to get another championship
and it does seem like
now's got to be the time if it's not now
when the heck is it going to happen
right now i mean check the ages out of
all the people that are frustrated
every age group right it's the guy that
you know you won when we're
i was eight years old and i've been
waiting 32 years for it you know
you won when i was 20 and now i'm i want
to get one before i pass away you know
and my my grandma
my grandfather are hanging on for dear
life to to get another dodger win so
yeah there's a lot of frustration it's
an amazing organization
not only because you know i'm here and
i'm a spokesman for them but
just look at the pedigree of what
they've done since the new ownership
took over since andrew friedman took
over
with the track record that he even met
coletti had with the mccourts as they
as they went through their trials and
tribulations but ned put some
really good pieces together in the minor
leagues and some good trades and brought
things together
and then andrew and stan caston and
everybody there at the organization has
finished it off with all these division
titles and world series appearances
but it's time to put it over the top and
and the whole organization is definitely
focused on that
oral herscheiser here on the rich eisen
show and i'm sure you've told the story
many times
but i don't know if you're aware but
today is in fact the anniversary
of 32 year anniversary of the gibson
home run it happened 32 years ago
tonight
against dennis eckersley i know if
you're aware that happy anniversary i
guess
uh in that respect for sure yeah well
certainly uh obviously uh you were a
crucial member of that team
walk me through your memories of that
night when gibson got
ready or and got out there and where you
were and all of that oral
well it was it was quite a night and uh
it started out on a downer because gibby
was so hurt he didn't even come out for
the announcements for the starting
lineups and then he was in the tv
room where i watched most of the game
because i wanted to scout the
oakland a's from the tv broadcast so
when we were on
defense i would go into the tv room and
watch and when we were on offense i'd
come out to the bench
that same in and out happened all the
way until the very end when gibby
was upset that vince scully had
announced as he panned the bench there
at dodger stadium with the television
cameras that gibby would not be
available to hit
but then that got gibby so mad that he
got mitch poole and
and some trainers to get some ice bags
on those hamstrings and to start numbing
him up
and then took a few swings down in the
tunnel and was able to get his uniform
on and
and able to say i can i can hit and the
message came down from mitch poole who
was
actually barked at i think from tommy
lasorda because what are you doing as a
clubby down on the bench bothering me in
the last
inning possible last inning of the world
series game one
but that message made it through and
tommy with uh his hollywood background
said keep him up the tunnel i don't want
anybody to know so
if all of a sudden gibby would have
appeared on the bench mr scully and the
television cameras would of course have
noticed it
and that would have given a message to
oakland and that would have probably got
to tony larussa and maybe he would have
managed the unique differently or maybe
eckersley would have
but they never got to know that and the
inning continued and
uh gibby came out of the dugout it was
uh it was like robert redford
it was unbelievable i was sitting next
to mike socia as i found out gibby was
going to hit
and told sosh and you know so
gibby's going to hit and he goes give he
can't walk he can't hit i go well he's
up there and he's got his hamstrings
numbed and he's taking a few swings and
he's going to
figure out a stance that he's not going
to fall over when he swings the bat
and then the rest of the story everybody
knows that
gibby being such a great teammate and
such a preparer
he read the whole scouting report that
was delivered to us by
mel didier and mr stevens
and they they gave it in person normally
it was just given written and kind of
handed to us at times but they gave it
actually in person
and uh skibby was there and prepared and
read the whole thing and
actually read to the the very end of the
scouting report which would be the
closer
and read about eckersley in the backdoor
curveball backdoor slider
to a left-handed batter if he gets to a
3-2 count
and we actually got to that count and
all we were hoping for was a single just
bloop one in the way he was swinging the
vat
but uh he ended up catching that slider
out front just
at the perfect moment and uh and put it
into the right field bleachers
i mean oral herscheiser just the fact
that you had a front row seat to have
to see you know all of it not just
from the home run but the fact that you
were
in the tv room with him during the game
and you're saying vince scully
pissed off kirk gibson
so much that he's like i'll show him and
that led to not only one of the
greatest moments in world series if not
dodger history but one of the greatest
calls of
the incredible career of who you i i
just noticed referred to as
i should as well mr scully um that's
what happened literally he was like
i'll show him i'll show everyone that
literally that's how it started
yeah it was the stimulus it was the the
finger in the side or the finger in the
eye
uh yeah that that pretty much started it
and uh
you know we might be the only world
championship team to have been inspired
by two television commentators because
then
we got inspired by bob costas when
tommy heard that we were the the worst
lineup ever
to take a field for as a world series
team and costas was reporting on that
and tommy turned up the tv and came in
and inspired the whole locker room with
that one
so and costas actually got thanked
at the end when we won because uh he
came by and interrupted tommy's post
game interview and said hey tommy
anytime you need that i remember
i remember the footage cost us walking
by and they interviewed costas with
tommy
in the post game interview even though
he was one of the reporters
and what did you think of when the ball
was in the air and it was hit because
again you
you you you knew how hurt he was you
knew how hurt gibson was you saw
everything unfold that night and the
fact that
you were just hoping for a bloop and
then maybe a blast later on but
the fact that he he actually left the
yard
what were you thinking as that ball was
in flight world hershey there's
multiple memories because the actual
memory is the first thing you check is
okay the crack of the bat you know
that's good the next thing you look at
is the right fielder which is conseco
and you see he's going back and then
it's like okay
please just be off the wall you know
just fall in hit outfield grass do
something hit the warning track
and then when you see him kind of give
up on the ball and it's out
that's when the bench all comes out and
there's the footage of everybody kind of
jumping through the camera lens because
everybody's jumping but the cameraman is
focused on the whole bench so it's a
long shot
and you see your head going in and out
of the of the of the telecast
because you're jumping up and down as
you're running towards home plate and
then
when gibby gets the home plate finally
after doing his pumps or
pump this you know around second base uh
he's
pushing us all off of him he's happy but
he's pushing us off him because the
weight of us
pounding on his shoulders and
congratulating him and hitting him on
the head
is going into his legs and it's killing
his legs he's like get off of me get off
of me
so and then he's trying to run around to
kind of celebrate a little bit but
you know i think the adrenaline in the
moment kind of made his legs feel better
and then i guess just for those of a
certain age who might be younger and
and are not at all as familiar with this
moment as clearly you are or
or i am or others um the man
who he hit it off of in terms of as
unhittable a pitcher as you've ever seen
eckersley at that time
was maybe the most unhittable pitcher
i've ever seen i mean
right i mean he he was dealing is not
the word for him
you know unbelievable movement with his
two-seam fastball to the corner low and
away to a lefty
unbelievable hit both sides of the plate
unbelievable slider yes he was
like unhittable i mean it's just it
wasn't just anybody we hit it off of it
really was
truly unbelievable uh before i let you
go oral i i very rarely bring up
somebody's wikipedia because it's very
rarely accurate but is it true
are you a professional poker player
that's what it says on your wikipedia
page i
i was for a few years yeah until black
friday when
it became illegal uh yeah i was
sponsored by poker stars for about five
years no kidding
yeah okay so it's a it's a fun sport
uh it's uh very interesting now as i get
older i'm 62 and all the young bucks
that are so good they've actually almost
solved the game so it's a very hard
sport now i'm probably
backing off a lot but uh the uh
it was a lot of fun when i took it up
and studied it right so
i mean how does it equate to pitching i
guess to any of you kind of the uh
the what talking to professional poker
players reading books watching videos
was one thing
but really understanding their brain and
then applying it to my baseball my
pitching
outline so what i mean by that is uh
first inning
you know want to keep the ball down want
to establish something that's kind of
like the same thing in poker when you
sit down at a table
you got to figure out what the lineup's
doing how they're reacting to you
and your pitches what side of the field
do i want the out am i on natural grass
or artificial turf
same thing in poker it's like okay am i
in the small blind am i in the big blind
what did i do with this guy last time i
had a flush draw can i
can i push him around with a fastball up
and in or do i need to actually
play this straight and not knock him
down with the you know a large bat
so it's there's a lot there of what i
thought about before i
through the pitch to the same thing in
poker of what i'm going to do before i
decide to bet or to
pass you know pass or what i want to do
you know muck the hand or do i want to
play this guy
well i'm asked i ask cause i'm
fascinated also it is my
nightly poker night tonight i don't have
a ci young award on my resume but i
think you might have just given me a
couple tips i'll be very honest with you
a little sit and go you play or you
actually played
yesterday it's it's a
it's a game it's a game it's it's a
friendly game it's a friendly game
it's a friendly game but if somebody
leaves a little bit follow me off the
air and i'll give you lessons
maybe 60 dollars a half hour that's a
that's a
i will take it oral thanks for the call
really appreciate it again like i get
what i said i really love listening to
uh your broadcast and uh let's make this
a regular thing
if not uh maybe another time this month
i appreciate it
all right you take care of it that's
oral herscheiser everybody that's oral
hershezer hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that
watch more right here